hello everyone and welcome to another
really awesome game from the penultimate
round of defeated candidates tournament
hikaru nakamura with the white pieces
against the yangxius of duda and even
though the tournament uh is basically
over yan uh yani pongashi won the one
defeated candidates tournament 2022 uh
we still don't know if magnus will play
or not so the second play uh all of a
sudden becomes incredibly important and
uh players are still fighting to have to
get that second place if magnus will not
want to play uh then nipple will play
against whoever wins the second place um
in defeating candidates tournament so uh
we're gonna discuss this a little bit
more uh but now let's uh check out the
game and also that here's a nice photo
of the match up there you have it um
the legend uh herself judith pogar
making the first move for hikaru
nakamura uh he is
enjoying the move and he might even
leave it on the board you did of course
a big e4 player uh hikaru decided to
leave the the move on the board and so
uh he opens with pawn to e4 or rather he
just keeps it on the board and just
writes it down and duda says uh he's
definitely up for a fight and goes for
the sicilian defense with knight to f3
d6 pawn to d for another open sicilian
knight to f6 knights the c3 ended the
best kind of sicilian there is the
neighbor of sicilian we have a pawn to
a6 bishop to e3 by hikaru going for the
english attack we have pawn to e5 and
knight just back to f3 bishop to e7 and
now h3 h6 and bishop to c4 so this is
all fairly standard stuff nothing new
here bishop to e6 challenging the bishop
and now bishop to bat to b3 you're not
really interested in capturing because
then uh
f captures an e6 just gives black a very
strong center and a very early support
for d5 yes you do weaken the g6 square
but this has all been analyzed so of
course they are not
worried about this with knight to c6 and
now uh the position has been reached
before knights the d5 is a non-mule
creek he'll be played against jose
cuardo martinez in 2021 us chess masters
uh with uh black winning this position
but here he car cowplays a move that has
never been played before and that is
knight to h4 uh usually uh a knight on
the rim isn't all that impressive but
here hikaru says no that's exactly what
the candidates tournament needs if in
order for him to look for some uh you
know imbalances in the position and
maybe look for for a chance to win uh
and okay uh now
what's the plan the plan is that we
we're going to capture the bishop now
and after pawn captures then we want to
put a knight on g6 but like we said this
isn't all that impressive and duda not
worried about that puts his knight on
the rim as well knight to a5 now he goes
after the bishop and uh
as the bishop will get traded that means
that duda will get access to the c4
square with his knights okay he called
trades bishop captures f captures and
knight the g6 that's a very nice square
for tonight but okay rook to g8 by duda
hikaru castles king side and now knight
to c4 just going after the bishop here
uh it's a beautiful square for the
knight and he carl brings it back bishop
to c1 so for the moment the rook is
stuck on a1 but of course we are
planning to kick away the knight with b3
and then maybe even put the bishop on
this diagonal so here rook the c8 by
doodah just continuing development h4 we
want to play h5 at some point um the the
king might harass that knight with king
to f7
rook to c6 and now queen to f3 we have
king to f7 now attacking the knight and
pawn to h5 we have queen to c7 doubling
up on the c file uh and now knights the
d1 hikaru doesn't want his c2 pawn to be
a target
uh so of course he moves the knight and
he wants to play pawn to c3 or or c4 all
depending on what duda plays so knight
back to b6 a dude are now threatening to
capture the c2 pawn and hikaru first
defends it knight to e3 we have knight
to d7 uh and uh now comes pawn to c4 now
the c4 square is guarded by the knight
so you don't have to play c3 you could
go for c4 right away knights to f8 now
going after the knight here and he car
just goes back knights to h4 he doesn't
want to unnecessarily trade pieces and
he wants the uh well just to keep
chances uh alive you could also just
play knight captures queen captures and
b4 which is perfectly fine uh but this
is uh sort of a must-win situation for
hikar if he wants to still be in uh
contingent forum maybe you know in some
sort of a scenario where magnus doesn't
play um uh uh you know challenger
challenge nepo for the title so knight
to f8 we have knight back to h4 by
hikaru and now knight the h7 uh but now
with the idea of bringing the knight to
g5 and if hikaru allows it then knights
the g5 comes with an attack on the queen
and you're gonna lose this e4 pawn and
interestingly uh this is exactly what
hikaru does he just plays b3 and it's uh
it's such a wonderful move to see you
know just giving up the e4 pawn like
that it's not an easy decision like okay
if if it somehow opened up this diagonal
for the bishop maybe yes but this way
it's very very hard to
uh to you know come up with a move like
this but hikaru does it knights the g5
uh duda goes after the queen here queen
back to e2 and now knight g captures an
e4 grabbing that pawn bishop to b2 and
now rook to e8 now dude wants to bring
his king back to g8 and uh well sort of
artificially castle uh we have knights
the g6 and now king to g8 we have rook
eight to d1 by hikaru and now pawn to a5
so what did the hikaru get for this pawn
sacrifice uh well uh look at the
beautiful placement of the knight the
bishop is still hitting that e5 square
but if black wants to play d5 at some
point in the game and well you played
the sicilian of course you want to play
d5 at some point in the game then the
position will open up and the bishop
could become a monster uh so very very
uh interesting position uh black
shouldn't really have any uh real
problems but uh hikaru is of course well
prepared for this and duda has to find
solutions over the board so here we have
knights to g4 now putting pressure on
the on the knight here uh and bishop
back to d8 so just uh
uh keeping uh the tension we have knight
captures on f6 knight captures on f6 and
now rook to d2 by hikaru
knight to d7 and now rook f to d1 just
doubling up on the d file you could also
play uh bishop to a3 to go after the
pawn this way but he cover plays rook
after d1 and now he allows duda this
very unpleasant bishop the g5 move
attacking he calls rook and now after
rook to d3
b5 and duda has a wonderful wonderful
position here he will shatter the queen
side and then uh well
you're still down upon let's not forget
that so here we have bishop to a3 by
hikaru going after the d6 pawn three
times now and the duda has to make a
choice and he makes the wrong one this
is one move that he i believe duda will
remember for a very very long time uh
because it's uh it's the it's basically
the definition of uh you know when
you've done everything properly uh with
black and the sicilian you play d5 then
you equalize or you know you're better
and then you continue playing uh and
here duda plays d5 but this is one
position where it's actually not all
that great here you have to play b4 uh
just stabilize the position here push
the bishop back and then a4 you want to
shatter this queen side structure so of
course if
b captures an a4 then you can start
capturing everything and if let's say
rook to g3 then you play a3 you grab
more space bishop to a1 and now knight
to f6 will be incredibly solid for duda
and only then after you know you you've
pretty much done everything you you have
to you will consider a move like d5 uh
but here after d5 right away this just
doesn't work he car plays c captures on
d5 and now you can't just capture back
if you just capture back then hikaru has
this very annoying f4 move and now of
course the pawn cannot capture because
the rook is hanging and uh
well bishop can capture for the same
reason because we capture with the
knight and again you can't capture back
because the rook is hanging and if
something like b4 attacks the bishop
then we just capture captures on g5 b
captures on a3 rook characters and d5
and white just has such a beautiful
position with so much pressure and that
black king
you will not have a lot of fun playing
this
so duda played rook to c2 and this was
his plan all along and here he car
surprised him with a very very annoying
move now the thing is objectively uh
rook the c2 is not a problem for white
white can meet this move in a variety of
ways you can play queen to f3 you can
push the pawn to d6 but the multi-card
plays is the trickiest one the strongest
one and it is the absolute absolute
strongest one recommended by the engine
and uh the move is bishop to d6 and this
is just uh wow
when luda saw this move he was very very
sad because uh well he missed it and
when he first saw it he was like uh
probably thought that he was much worse
now even though uh you know the the
evaluation is that the position is dead
equal uh but still he's very low on time
he still needs to make five more moves
to reach time control and then hikaru
just surprises him with this and the
the most annoying part i believe for
duda was uh the he played the move and
then he left the playing hall and then
when he returned hikaru already left as
he played his move and then he saw this
move on the board and he was just you
know like shaking his head uh it was
terrible
uh but in the end he decided to go for
the uh rook captures on e2 line which
seems to be not the the nicest one but
you know for just for fun we can show
what happens if he captures on d5
because that's also playable so we're
gonna trade like this bishop captures
here rook captures on e2 rook captures
on d5 now attacking the knight knight to
f6 attacks the rook and the rook
captures on b5 knight captures on h5
real captures an a5 and now now you have
this position where he car would have to
connect it pass pawns on the queen side
but the duda can start pushing the e
pawn and with all of the the pieces next
to the white king duda would have um uh
well
it would not be
very straightforward but you will be
able to play this out to to a draw uh
however there is a much simpler way and
that of course is rook captures on e2
this is what the duda played bishop
captures on c7 and now knight to c5 just
attacking the rook and this is where
hikaru really uh really gave it to duda
uh nicely because duda was extremely low
on time and he was probably expecting he
covered just to move the roof probably
something like rook to c3 rook to h3
rook to f3
probably the moves that he considered
but he carl played the d6 he sacrifices
the exchange and the duda again i
believe was not happy to see this just
because there's not enough time to
calculate everything and it's not an
easy thing to capture this rook just to
give you a few examples if you capture
the knight then hikaru has a variety of
options he could play well not the
variety
there are actually two options you could
just capture the knight or push the pawn
to d7 both are very very interesting so
for example if rook captures on d3 uh e4
charging the rook pawn to d7 now rook to
a8 luckily we have the bishop and the
recovering the square
but you know it's not all that great
rook to d6 getting the rook out of
harm's way now you have to play
something and now knight to e5 uh so
what can you do here king to h7 and now
rook captures an e6 and you get this
position where
it's not easy to play this but you are
you are surviving you still have control
over the d8 square and you you're
fighting on so this is one of the
options uh the other one after knight
captures on d3 is to just go for a
straightforward d7 and which could be
even be the more trickier one uh because
after the rook moves rook to a8 we're
gonna play rook captures on d3 now rook
captures on a2 and now uh bring a queen
into the game bishop captures bishop
captures and now pawn to a4 here duda
would would get a nice pass pawn
captures captures and yes it's uh bishop
and knight against the rook which is of
course better for hikaru uh but the two
rooks featuring the the outside pass
pawn
uh could be very uh
very tough to play against so these are
the options but uh uh all in all after
d6 definitely by far the best option for
duda is just to capture this rook
however duda uh he uh probably just
didn't have time to calculate it
although it goes back knight to d7 and
now it's uh well it's just all hikaru
from here and now hikaru grabs the a5
pawn and duda without all that many
moves here you have to go for the pawn
rook captures on a2 now bishop to b4 and
now the pawn is just beautifully
defended on d6 it's a monster pass pawn
with hikaru not really having to
sacrifice anything to together there if
you if you look at the board now it is
equal material and well hikar just has a
beautiful pass pawn on d6
and here duda almost uh ran out of time
completely he played bishop to d8 with
12 seconds on the clock
and it's not the the absolute greatest
move uh so what you want to do here is
uh you want to play something like rook
here you want to put the disc rook to b2
you want to bring this rook over here to
put more pressure on the f2 pawn then
you want to play bishop to d8 to b6 to
put even more pressure on f2 and hope
that somehow all of this pressure on the
second rank and the and the f2 square is
enough to hold the draw that's basically
the only thing you can do and i think
duda went for this only he went with
bishop to d8 first and that um
that simply doesn't uh it doesn't work
as well because now he car replaced rook
the c3 and now this rook the c7 move
will be will be extremely annoying uh
bishop to b6 played by duda this is now
move 40 so time control has been reached
and also i believe around move 40 uh or
rather on move 39 so uh hikaru still
hasn't the reach time control he started
uh like it looked like he was being very
annoyed uh that something was happening
uh you know where the crowd was supposed
to be and then he just started laughing
so you know no one knew what was
happening uh but then later i read on
twitter how uh anishigiri apologized
that he was distracting hikaru who knows
maybe he was just you know goofing
around or something uh and that he was
you know just hoping that uh hikaru you
know manages to win this a great
position because if he doesn't you know
he could blame geary in his next video
so i thought that was important to
mention uh but yeah here uh king the h2
by hikaru a very classy move uh the idea
being
white wants to play rook to c7 and uh
of course a bishop captures pawn
captures uh this pass pawn will be
unstoppable plus all the pressure on the
d file the problem is you have rook
captures on f2 and now threatening all
sorts of nasty discoveries you're going
to have to waste the move to play king
to h2 uh you know either way so hikaru
just does it right away king to h2 and
he says this is always a threat i don't
have to write this but king to h2 must
be played and here duda plays king to h7
another very very interesting move but
capturing the f2 pawn was was
well it wasn't essential or anything
because it's still incredibly difficult
to play this rook the c7 is still coming
you have to play something but the good
thing is that now after you capture on
f2 you can play rook to f7 but still
rook to b7 you put pressure on the
bishop it's you know you're threatening
knight captures here then knight
captures so
this would be the way to go maybe it's a
little bit better but uh it's definitely
it's very hard to say here dude i played
king to h7 but now pawn to f3 he car no
longer offers the f pawn we have rooked
back to a7 defending the the c7 square
but now rook to c6 again with the same
idea just the knight captures knight
captures and we eliminate the bishop on
b6 so bishop to e3 by duda and bishop to
d2 hikaru now wants to get rid of the
bishops as uh his position is just much
better so it makes sense uh bishop to d
for bishop to c3 and duda now again
happily repeating bishop to e3 he would
be of course very happy with the draw by
repetition but now hikaru goes for rook
to c7 attacks the rook attacks the
knight uh and you can't really capture
it if you captured then you know we just
have this beautiful pawn the knight is
hanging and uh you cannot defend the
knight and you cannot move the knight
because of rook c8 so you just resign
here so instead after rook to c7 rook 8
the e8 was played
but it is much too late for such things
here we have king the h3 by hikaru you
could also play rook to a1 but there are
many ways to win this this is just the
uh the the super fun way you know just
getting the
uh
rook away from the the the defense of
the knight here uh and then if of course
we'll capture so we can just capture and
keep the tension on the on the seventh
rank but okay king to h3 works just as
well duda plays b5 uh b4 to activate the
rook on the b file but hikaru just grabs
rook to b8 and now bishop back to c3
rook captures on b3 and now we have this
amazing rook to c8 hikaru freed the
eighth rank for his rook and now rook
the h8 is the threat of checkmate rook
has to go back rook to b8 and now hikaru
finally starts trading rook captures
knight captures and here hikaru pushes
these seven and he was in this position
on move uh 52 that youngs used to do
that resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here the problem
is even though you are defending this
pawn twice uh if you capture with the
rook we just capture back or even better
just knight to f8 to check and that's it
we pick up the rook the rook is now
attacked twice so the position on h7 for
the king isn't all that great and uh
well the king did not belong there
especially not when duda played this and
of course if you capture with the knight
we just capture with the rook and after
rook captures then we deliver the fork
we pick up the
uh the rook and now we have an extra
piece of course this would be completely
winning so incredible incredible stuff
hikaru uh
read the position absolutely correctly
uh here uh
in such a such a tricky position uh
after uh here after this bishop captures
in c7 move and knight to c5 uh hear that
uh you know you should just continue
moving forward because duda was very low
on time there were five or more moves
that needed to be made until time
control and hikaru just went for a
practical move rather than a safe one
and you know it paid off so really
really awesome stuff by hikaru and what
does this mean for the standings well
for the standings that this means that
uh nepal okay we already said that nip
who won the tournament he's a 9 out of
13. he's an absolute monster but hikaru
now in second place with seven and a
half out of 13.
now what does this mean uh it means that
if
magnus decides not to defend his title
like there is a possibility for that
then it matters a lot who has second
place and hikaru now definitely has the
best best chances to uh
finish second in the tournament if he
wins tomorrow then of course uh he
absolutely uh wins win second place no
questions ask if he if he draws and ding
wins then uh i i don't know who has the
better tie breaks but it's going to be
very interesting but that doesn't really
matter all that much uh because tomorrow
uh hikaru is playing ding so it can't uh
you know happen that hikaru gets a draw
and the ding wins uh so it's gonna be
it's definitely the best uh final round
and it's it's it's good that now we
don't know if magnus will be playing
because now uh there is no way we see a
draw in the dinky car game or you know a
boring berlin or something like that
it's gonna be pieces will be flying all
over the place uh
uh you know and ding has the white
pieces so will he go for some sort of a
wild english or will he go for e4 i
think ding goes for e for tomorrow uh
probably
uh but yeah i don't know about the the
other guys probably okay um it's very
very very hard to see but yeah i don't
think uh the the other guys have a
chance because okay maybe if uh
no uh they don't they don't have a
chance yeah i i think only ding and
hikaru can now uh call uh you know
get second place uh as they are playing
each other so uh will be it will be
extremely interesting to see uh what
happens tomorrow so we're gonna have a
great final round uh these are the
standings uh after the penultimate run
so i hope you enjoyed that as well uh
and yeah uh really enjoying the
candidates tournament really looking
forward to the final round and hope you
guys are enjoying the the short
recaps as well uh even though the videos
are a bit longer than they usually are
when we're covering casual games but
what are you gonna do uh so yeah once
again really hope you guys enjoyed it uh
i would like to thank jeffrey cook
abhishek babu gregory thomas gideon
franklin and jim tran for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament until it finishes
uh so thank you all i will see you soon
and have an excellent rest of your day